what can Congress do to stop the surge
Senator Marco Rubio joins us with his
insights welcome Senator Rubio we have
some breaking news coming out of the
house they have voted a long party lines
to pass a rules package to promote and
pass through a bill that would codify
remain in Mexico from what I can see it
only seems to be Republicans who are
putting forth a solution that's actually
getting a vote your thoughts
well first of all I think that it's
pretty bad there's a hundred thousand
people near the border about ready to
pounce but I want you to know that there
is at least another 500 000 people in
route and that's what we're getting from
our friends in Costa Rica Panama
Colombia you've seen a massive surge of
people that are moving in that direction
so this is not a one-night thing you
know this is not going to be tomorrow
night at midnight you know everybody
comes over and then it's done there are
people in transit they are in route and
you've got all these cartels and
trafficking networks that are ready to
pounce on this and take advantage of it
look here's the problem this is a nation
that has offered Asylum to people for
decades but there comes a point where a
process is being abused and you have to
put an end to it we have to change the
criteria for Asylum we have to change
the correct right now people know if you
come across the border and you ask for
Asylum you trigger a series of legal
procedures that are going to largely for
the most part let you get released into
the country pending and immigration
hearing at some time in the future that
many people don't even show up for the
word is out and it's pretty clear not to
mention the disinformation that's being
applied and told people that uh tomorrow
night will be legal across the border so
we have in essence about five to six
hundred thousand people are going to try
to enter the United States these are
images that we're used to seeing out of
Syria and out of places like that we've
never seen this in America before and
this I mean I think yesterday the number
was eleven thousand I think that number
is going to double and it's really going
to become a I think we're headed toward
a potential cataclysm here that has no
uh no precedent and at this point it's
almost too late to stop it because the
Biden administration's policy is up to
this point you know doubling numbers
that are already at historic highs it's
inconceivable meanwhile you have two
colleagues John tester and Senator Braun
today they were chased down the halls of
Congress we know that's what the
journalists do in the halls there they
were asked about title 42 and their
words were we're not ready for this we
need to extend it they say on their way
to lunch they seem a little late to the
ball game on this
yeah no look extending it'd be fine but
at this point you know the truth of the
matter is only about 30 percent of the
people or less are being turned away at
the border the rest are still getting in
as is that doesn't do anything about the
huge surge of migration that's already
there and present that just threatens to
overwhelm us all of this is happening by
the way because the perception and the
reality that if you make it to the U.S
border and you cross over your chances
of getting to stay in the United States
are very very high even with title 42 in
place without it all that's done is just
create all that pent-up demand over a
shorter period of time this is the
potential to be the cataclysm like I
said we've never seen images like this
before what we're about to see over the
next few days and I think it's going to
lead to all sorts of things that are
unanticipated you know Migrant Center
uprisings and riots I mean this is just
Mass migration events are never good
ever and meanwhile our call my colleague
bill malusian is reporting that the
Biden Administration is just going to
let illegal migrants out on the streets
if the ngos fill up and we know that
they will Senator Marco Rubio thank you
for joining me hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else